bbc reports
russia threatens to stop supplying gas
if not paid in rubles i don't i don't
like these headlines i scoured google
for a headline that was actually getting
into nitty gritty but it's more than
that vladimir putin has signed a decree
stating buyers must open ruble accounts
in russian banks that is very different
nobody sells anything for free and we're
not going to do charity either putin's
demand is being seen as attempt to boost
the ruble which has been hit by western
sanctions while it's working the ruble
is recovering but this is more about
russia's banks they say his decree means
foreign buyers of russian gas would have
to open an account at russia's gazprom
bank and transfer euros or u.s dollars
into it gazprom bank would then convert
this into rubles which will then be used
to make the payment for gas he's not
saying you have to buy the oil and gas
he's saying you have to open an account
and put your money into it he's propping
up the russian financial system because
of western sanctions he's now got the
mere payment system visa and mastercard
and amex and all these companies
suspending he doesn't care all joe biden
has done with his sanctions is bolster
russia and make them fiercely
independent strong and weaken the u.s uh
us's position around the world so um and
you're right thank you thanks joe biden
i can't believe that's something joe
biden intended to do had the reverse
effect
this is unbelievable to me because he
said you know but that this is what they
say about smooth talkers you know can't
trust them it's got that silver tongue
but the follow through just isn't there
yeah but it's not it's it's it's it's
also that he's he he tries to walk back
or claim things never happened that
never happened it hasn't happened none
of that happened well with the sanctions
i think he was asked by ducey who's like
the only journalist asking questions he
was asked uh you know these sanctions
were supposed to deter putin and they're
not and then it was one of the
spokespeople for the administration
they're like no no we never said that oh
no i think biden said by himself but he
actually doesn't remember bro go easy on
him he's like i didn't say that man
alone that was a very telling video
ducey brought up three things he said
that was a different one okay i'm saying
that he was asked specifically you said
sanctions were going to deter putin he's
like well no i didn't and then there you
there's quotes from the biden edmond
where they were like the sanctions will
deter putin and they didn't it's you
know what it is it's like blinking and
kamala and uh uh biden are like the
three stooges
and they're slipping around on banana
peels
and putin's just going off and doing
whatever he wants man
you say something once on the internet a
video it's there forever essentially i
mean not forever but
i don't think he understands that
because he's from an old generation
before the internet right right like
remember when hillary clinton put on a
southern accent when she was in alabama
hot sauce oh the hot sauce one too and
she ran uh breakfast club yeah what do
you always keep in your bag hot sauce
you have hot dogs in here i carry it
everywhere but she put on a fake
southern accent because she didn't she
didn't realize that people record
everything these days she's old right
yeah back in the day you could show up
anywhere and speak however you wanted
aoc even did it you know remember she
she put on like an uh like an urban
latina accent or dialect or whatever and
then she was like that's just how i talk
it's like we hear you on on pbs we hear
you on cnn like you don't talk that way
right it's so it's it's it's creepy but
you know what you get it you're a sales
guy right oh yeah well she's trying to
reflect the people she's talking to but
at the same point in time there comes a
fine line between being your authentic
self and being condescending and i mean
we talk about joe biden hillary clinton
aoc nancy pelosi there's one thing that
they all represent it's condescension
you know what it is it's like um
it's like the the upper middle class
lady who orders something at a mexican
restaurant in broken english because she
like assumes that the waiter please
don't dad sentences please don't yeah
you're like please stop doing this like
they're not even trying to speak spanish
they're just speaking english poorly
intentionally it's like what are you
doing yo senor yo necesito more guac
yeah
but that's broken spanish they will
literally do brokenness like i want
food for plate you're like bro you can
just talk normally like they'll
understand you remember that yale study
that says white liberals
talk down they they dumb down their the
way they speak to black people and
conservatives don't mm-hmm that's the
crazy yo like here's the thing i don't
dump down my speech to anyone because it
like it can't get any dumber
for me personally but these liberals are
just so smart they have to condescend
down to the rest of us the cdc is
calling me right now should i answer it
oh yeah this is the center for disease
control that's probably definitely a
legitimate comment i would say it's
probably the cdc yeah should i it says
cdc national immune
show i'm just saying i'm along for the
ride hold on i'm gonna try to answer
this uh
hello i am i am live broadcasting right
now is this a cdc we're live streaming
on the internet
we're doing a live uh talk show right
now just so you know they're like you
know everyone's able to hear what you
say are you okay with that
yeah okay all right that's probably that
that would probably be better otherwise
we've got you know you know a lot of
people who are watching
all right thanks man
yeah call back later what is the cdc
doing a survey for uh you you heard that
yeah did you like our uh did you like
our services the last couple years what
do you think what did you think of the
advice that we were giving to the public
scale of one to ten how much do you
trust the cdc today how satisfied are
you
yeah they have their tax dollars been
going to the right spotlight yeah maybe
not they've actually been calling me a
lot because we got it and then and then
if you answer no you take the survey and
you answer that you're not satisfied
they're like this guy's sick we got to
quarantine this one like round them up
they come out with like the hazmat suits
like they're in china you jump out the
window they grab you bring it back in
yeah they called me at 3 51. i really
wanted they called me let's see let's
say 351 today uh 320 today
they called me yesterday what they were
trying to reach you about your vaccine's
extended warranty bro
that's really weird i don't think they
called me at all did you guys get that
here by the way like people going around
door-to-door asking if you you got your
vacs no no that was a thing in philly
and it was weird this guy like he comes
up to my house and my wife and i just
moved out of philadelphia and he knocks
on the door he's like hi sir i'm from
the city of philadelphia and i'm just
going around to check out people are
doing during covid see if uh you know
obviously you had the opportunity to get
your vaccine i'm like
i don't really want to answer that
question he goes well did you get your
vaccine like okay well that's what
they're that's what they're calling for
100 so so i got a text message from them
uh none of it was a voicemail it was a
voicemail and uh
what did they say i thought it was a
scam to be honest oh here we go
yeah they said i'm calling on behalf of
the cdc conducting a national
immunization survey about vaccinations
for covet and other diseases please call
us back or whatever and they called me
well uh cdc if you call me i just want
to let you let you know
it will be live yes and so that's uh
your decision what up cdc i have so many
questions anyway we were talking about
you know what's going on in europe and
then the cdc called me during the show i
i get i get phone calls periodically
during the show i don't answer them but
with the cdc calls really yeah
i thought it was really interesting like
is there a new disease did a new new
variant drop what's going on
what if it was like i heard you were
doing my voice in these cartoons
i am sending you a cease and desist i
should be the one making those royalties
off of my own likeness yeah that's fair
but yeah uh i didn't actually think
anybody would be able to hear it but um
that was awesome you know i asked them
if they were okay with it
yeah no
respectable i guess such as like but i i
didn't know what they were calling for
so i thought it'd be interesting you
know we'd do a show we're talking about
this stuff um but where where were we
we're rubble
i think they're the part of the reason
it's backfired but part of the reason
why the ruble bounded back not only did
they set up on gold but
it's it's its value is calculated in
relative to the dollar so if the dollar
drops in value the ruble is going to go
up relatively in value so as the dollar
keep continues to plummet as it's
continued to be printed you're going to
see all of these other currencies going
up it's actually that's actually a
really good point um everybody's looking
at the ruble going back up and they're
assuming it's all of these things putin
is doing it could just be all the things
biden is doing destroying the dollar oh
literally that's true biden the fed yeah
across the board it's been a blast like
there's no real is there an independent
way to measure the value of your
currency up against something
well when mastercard visa and all these
companies pull out of russia
and
that's another part of it so it is
they put them in a corner they say if
you don't you're gonna you know we're
gonna buy your oil with with euros but
we can shut off your euro accounts at
any moment like why would he take that
deal i don't think he's doing anything
out of the ordinary
no i'm not saying i love it i'm just
saying it's not
when you look at what the the biden
administration has done from a foreign
policy standpoint we were talking about
this beforehand like it has been one
unforced mitigated disaster after
another and i think it's just a matter
of and it's sad to say but i think putin
looks at it as he just he has to
maintain himself long enough to outlast
biden and these failed policies until
you're and we're seeing this right now
your average person's like this is this
is not worth it i i i mean maybe
but i also think
as soon as joe biden got elected you
know you know you know how they would do
they would do the show the west wing
where it's like that that camera in
front of as they walk and then it turns
the corners imagine that with putin and
and then you know his guy's like
sir
joe biden is president you have four
years and then he's like let's move and
then they start like nailing out all
their plans like we're on the clock
people we got four years to get this
done because as soon as biden's out
you're going to get a donald trump or
ronda sanchez or something so putin
knows the iron is hot now is his chance
it's like the purge for all of our
potential foreign adversaries we have
like a small window where we can do
whatever we want
once every hundred years the u.s elects
a buchanan or uh or a bite you think
biden's gonna run again i hear that he
is this is i don't know where this came
from pacific maybe yeah
come on dude i walk again hold on hold
on hold on hold on he's gonna he's gonna
have his walker oh you literally run
again no he's not gonna do that again
he's still biting not holding his hand
without stem cells or something
maybe he's erp
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there